our friend from sports illustrated and
the man who writes the mmqb every single
week joining us from indianapolis
indiana albert brewer how's the weather
albert what's going on it's absolutely
beautiful i mean you remember the super
bowl here oh
oh yes it's it sort of feels like that a
little bit like where you know and and
both you and i have been here one of
zero degrees and there's black ice
everywhere
um this is this is actually pretty
pleasant i mean
maybe not quite like uh what the super
bowl was they're pretty close um i
walked i i went for a run this morning
in shorts oh and um yeah and uh and i'm
not wearing a jacket right now oh wow
win-win okay very good thank you for
painting that picture albert i
appreciate that so uh what is the story
of the combine what do you got for me
what is it right now when you're coming
in you're thinking all right i need to
write a bunch of uh uh our columns
articles like what what interests you or
do you think is the the story of the of
the 2022 scouting combine well as you
know like rachel like there's two
separate tracks here there's like what's
going on in the league in general and
then there's what's happening with the
draft you know and i think what's going
on in league with general is just uh i
think continued
sort of
i guess like like i i don't even know
like the continuing like coming together
of what's going to happen at the
quarterback position across the league
and so
you know that's that's aaron rodgers
it's kyla murray it's russell wilson um
you know and so
i think that you'd hope that those
things crystallize over the next few
days um you know and by the time you you
leave indy which is a week away from the
beginning it's really a year it's a
better idea what's going to happen with
the biggest names at quarterback and
then
as far as draft class goes um yeah i
like and and this is you know going back
six months of phone calls and talking to
people about it and you know going
watching college football it's just
this this draft class probably lacks
like a you know miles garrett or chase
young certainly doesn't have a trevor
lawrence or joe burrow
but you know like once you get past you
know 10 15
um then all of a sudden i think that
most teams see it as is having really
great value and the interesting thing
about that is
a huge part of it is the backlog of
players who went back to school because
of covid
and um so you have like a a pretty large
number of players in general in this
year's class for teams to sort through
and and i think that's going to hit over
the next two or three years it's going
to continue because there are you know
the quote unquote super seniors guys who
you know spent six years in school
and then you know guys who because 2020
was just sideways a year wind up coming
back in 21.
um you know you got younger players who
maybe aren't starting as early because
of that so
um there's a good gaps in this year's
group and um you know i think some of
the positions that people here have
talked about um receiver edge rusher
obviously your michigan guy could be
number one overall an offensive tackle
so there's like
there's there's pretty good quality
if there isn't like a jamar chase or uh
you know again like a miles garrett at
the top of the draft of those positions
there's a lot of quality depth at both
those spots and at the offensive tackle
so i mean um what's the consensus going
in and i know this is fraught um
because it might change going out in the
year that baker was number one it was a
no doubt about it coming out of the
combine because he'd lit it up that
saquon barkley was going to be first
overall then we all know he wasn't but
what's the general sense coming in who's
first overall going into the combine you
know what's interesting so like i think
you know
the way most people look at it like
aidan hutchinson's got the best i i
think is the closest thing to a walk to
go in the top two
but things are really fluid with the
first overall pick the consensus i've
gotten is that aiden hutchinson probably
won't make it past the lions at two just
i mean it goes beyond just the natural
geographic connection
um you know stylistically he's a fit for
for dan campbell obviously from a
culture standpoint um he's everything
that that both you know campbell and
brad holmes want
so you know like i think you know if you
were talking about a shirt bet to go in
the top two i think it's aiden
hutchinson
um
you know i i think what's happening at
one is is fluid because there are teams
that believe aiden hutchins is the best
player in the draft
um you know k von thibodeaux obviously
has you know considerable upside so you
maybe consider him
you know up there too
but then there's some really good
offensive tackles the one name that i
think people are going to come out of
here talking about is the nc state
offensive tackle um it can
and um he
i'm told was going to test like tristan
wurtz did you know a couple of years ago
where not only he's gonna run a fast 40
but he's gonna blow out all the physical
testing
and um you know it's early but i've
already heard the jaguars connected to
him which makes sense because if you
look at the offensive line that doug
peterson won a super bowl with um in
philadelphia there were a lot of really
athletic linemen and that's what equano
is so
um you know i think you know
my guess would be that the first overall
picks could be one of the four
um you know the two tackles the quantum
and and avid neil um and then
one of the two pass rushers in
hutchinson or or caveman thibodeaux but
i think the first takes a little bit
more fluid where most people i think
look at the second pick and they're like
yeah if aiden hutchinson slips by one
the lions are taking them at two albert
breer from the mmqb sports illustrated
here on the rich eisen show then let's
now move to what's going on outside
um the combine and last year russell
wilson was that disgruntled nfc west
quarterback that nobody really
kind of saw coming um there were some
rumblings or something about that and
then we heard a list of teams that he
would be considered maybe uh not being a
seahawk anymore and then nothing came of
it because he never really demanded a
trade now we've got kyler murray whose
um agent sent out a treatise on an
excellent piece of stationery yesterday
and after having thought about it albert
my only two my only thought is why do
this unless you're priming the pump or
trying to speak to the jury
in advance of demanding out if you don't
get what you want
is that a possibility that kyla murray
will eventually say
the contract that's on the table if i
don't get what i want long term i'm
going to demand a trade i'm done with
the cardinals good luck
here's what i think is unique about it
is that coach and quarterback are so
aligned um you know and i i'm sure
you've had people tell you this they're
the same agent
um and you know i think you know the
primary reason why the cardinals were
willing to move off of josh rosen in
2019
and go with kyle and murray was because
cliff had such deep belief in kyla right
like and really thought like this is the
guy we need to build around
um and so you know i think so much of
where kyler is ties right back to cliff
and here's why this is what i think is
really unique about it
you go back to the last week of the the
last week of the the cardinals season
obviously didn't go the way they wanted
right like so they they lose that game
and pretty in pretty ugly fashion to the
to the rams in l.a
and my understanding is that was an
uncomfortable awkward week in that
building and
like they had a personnel meeting like a
normal personality at the end of the
year abruptly canceled like other coach
coaches didn't know whether or not they
were safe
um so for you know good week there
uh people in that building were very
very uncomfortable feeling like the
owner might do something and that um and
eventually like that's settled down
but i mean there's been no declarative
statement coming out like oh yeah like
cliff's our guy
and cliff's going into a contract here
too
so
you know i think beyonce's this being
like the sort of decision point which
you and i have talked about where after
three years it sort of becomes decision
time for for teams on their first round
quarterbacks there's also that second
piece to it where
you know i think tyler feel like i think
kylo feels like if he waits right
and the cardinals have already started
to kick the can down the road on him
contractually
if he were to wait till after year four
was cliff's going to be gone then and
then the idea of getting a new contract
out the window altogether
um that's why i think it's just such an
interesting situation and i don't think
that this should be overlooked either
i mean tyler's former college teammate
baker mayfield
wound up waiting for a year
and he was eligible for a contract last
year didn't get one and now where's he
left you know so i think that there's a
number of different likes
i think a number of different like
factors that sort of play into kyler's
urgency to try to get a contract now but
what i mean if they
moved
you know uh they they completely up
ended their plan to draft him the plan
being rosen and wilkes now obviously
rosen and wilkes quarterback coach
combination they they just
you know didn't want to go down that
road anymore or murray made them change
their mind but the bottom line is they
totally blew it up right for him correct
and then they wound up adding deandre
hopkins
for him
and they clearly have been you know all
about those guys let's get james connor
let's
let's do all of it bring bring in as
many players as they possibly can uh
zach hurts mid-season just keep on
improving um and uh the coach is
close to him and and
so put it all together is where does the
where does the bad blood come from where
does the instagram account
um being scrubbed come from where does
the
feeling the need yeah to put out a
statement that leads folks like myself
to wonder okay the only reason to do
this is to say when i'm say i i'm out of
here don't blame us i've already let you
know through my agent that i desperately
want to win a super bowl and i
absolutely want to be your long-term
quarterback i mean where's where's the
where's where's the disconnect here
three three magic words that can guide
you
everywhere you need to go in the nfl
rich and you know what those words are
follow the money
um you know i
my my understanding is they did you know
and i think eric burkhart his agent put
this in the letter but they did approach
the cardinals about a deal and the
cardinals basically told him to stand
down and said you know we'll take care
of you but it's not going to be right
now might be later in the off season
that's my understanding of how that went
down
and so you know i think that kyler's
hyper aware
of the fact that again this is sort of
when you in this system um that's been
in place since 2011 make your decision
on your first round quarterback whether
or not you're going forward with him or
not and if you look at the history of it
after year three is when josh allen got
a deal it's when deshawn watson got a
deal it's when patrick mccombs got a
deal is when carson wentz and jared goff
got a deals so teams that have been
assured
that they have the right guy
will typically do deals after year three
so this feeling that maybe they're not
going to do a deal with me now and then
again like looking at what it could look
like in year four having seen what
happened with baker in cleveland and you
know having a relationship with baker
and then maybe looking at it and saying
is close gonna be here in my fourth year
like if you're asked in my fifth year if
you're asking those questions well then
yeah i mean i think that that's where
you say
if they're not paying me now
is there some sort of ulterior motive
there where they don't want to hitch
their wagon to me
because they think things could look
significantly different a year from now
so um and it's a fair thought i mean
it's just i mean if you think of i mean
it's it's to me like it's a fair thought
because
like you've seen the way these things go
with guys who wait and like look at
again look at baker mayfield right now a
year ago you might have said yeah the
browns are going to take care of them at
some point now it looks like they may
never take care of them so i understand
where that thought comes from so are we
seeing a new normal in a way albert or
just to settling in after having the
system
be the way it is five-year contracts for
first-rounders uh
after the third year you've got to pick
up a fifth year option
that we're we're now seeing
that if a quarterback doesn't get a deal
after year three
that's now a breaking point is that what
we're seeing right now
yeah and i think it's sort of the trade
off with the rules because you know the
owners were adamant about putting that
rule in in 2011 because they had had
players come back after two years
and hold out like you remember the chris
johnson hold out all those years ago
that was after two years so they wanted
to make sure that they'd be in a
position where
players would have to wait until the
third year the problem with that the
flip side of it is
you take away the gray area and you
really like draw a line of the sand
there where it's like if you really love
me
then you're going to take care of me as
soon as you can and as soon as you can
as after year three so
i think for players and it's not just
the extension it's also you got to make
a decision on the fifth year option
right so you know players are thinking
about those sorts of things in advance
and you get after year three and you
feel like your team may be kicking a can
down the road a little bit
and you're not in a secure position as
say andrew luck was who waited four
years or cam newton was who waited four
years
and yeah i mean i think there's
definitely that in the back of your head
where it's like maybe
i'm maybe i'm not going to be here long
term so yeah i mean i i think you look
at the history of the last five years
of of what's happened after three years
with the with quarterbacks who were
drafted in the first round
and history tells you
that teams that are very sure about the
guys that they have
take care of them after the third year
and i think because of that because that
history is now built up quarterbacks who
aren't taken care of after the third
year are going to see it as a red flag
well i mean obviously tyler does right
albury here on the rich eisen show
because it used to be
prior you said 2011 that was the year of
the lockout where i lost my hair and you
had to keep getting new pairs of shoes
because they were worn out of you
standing on a street corner in
washington dc with us talking to each
other on nfl network is that you know
owners uh in the nfl sick and tired of
giving kids who had not played a single
down in the nfl
the most amount of money in the history
of their franchise because they were
drafted first overall just like matthew
stafford for instance when he came in
the highest paid uh player in the
history of the lions boom they say they
want to see a few years on the field
before making somebody the highest paid
player in the history of the franchise
and thus
this new system came in
but
at the same time they also wanted to
make sure they could win a super bowl in
that first contract because they didn't
have to pay that person that much money
and you could pay other people around
him and you could win and that's the
jackpot that's what happened with
russell wilson when he was drafted in
the third round though but that's what
happened with mahomes that's the jackpot
you're saying now though that prospects
are pushing up right after year three
so maybe teams need to make sure that
they they leave some money for year four
and five to do that now i'm
i'm just fascinated by this subject
matter because when it all comes down to
it murray clearly is generationally
talented why won't the cardinals pay him
then what's the point in that yeah i
mean and that's that's the question that
they're gonna have to answer here like
you know like why they haven't been more
aggressive to pay them um because i mean
like look there the fact is they have
gotten better three years in a row i
know like the the ends of these seasons
haven't gone the way they wanted um but
you know what cliff and kyler walked
into was i mean arguably the worst
situation in the league and the roster
was 32 out of 32 when they got there the
record was 32 out of 32. and they won 11
games this year and they've
progressively gotten better year by year
um and so you know i
like i don't know what the hesitation is
but clearly you know kyler is worried
that this could lead to something other
than him getting a contract extension
over the summer um because
again like my understanding is like what
they've said to him is we'll take care
of him just later in the off-season
and clearly it seems like kyler doesn't
fully trust that and maybe again it's
because he feels like he's tied to cliff
and because
because if cliff's on shaky ground maybe
that means he's on shaky ground it's i
mean to me it's fascinating because it's
yeah it's unique it's
you see certain parts of it like you're
talking about rich where it could be a
trend like the year three thing the
after year three thing but on the other
side of it like there's stuff that's
very unique to the situation such as the
relationship between kyle and cliff
specifically and then there's the case
of lamar jackson albert breer and and
now before i let you go i want to talk
lamarr here because we've already just
talked about how baker mayfield was told
to wait and now waiting that fourth year
instead of getting the contract after
his third year we're wondering if the
browns are gonna just let him play it
out and then move on from him
um and then you've got kyler murray who
might be like the the
the uh the first guy to test this system
by saying if i don't get my contract
after year three i'm out and in the
middle of all of it is lamar jackson
who's unsigned because he's representing
himself and really doesn't
feel the need to get around to it is
that what is that what i'm hearing yeah
and i i think that the i mean it's i
mean that's unique for that reason
because he's representing himself and um
i don't know if you've ever
personally talked to a contract
negotiator on the other side of the
table um without having any to afford
you rich but i have and like i know like
i
i know how that can feel sometimes you
know what i mean like so
um that's that that's the that's the
tough thing about this one is it's
delicate because
well you know
where do you come in like and
like yeah you maybe feel like you can't
come in too low if you're the ravens and
you just have to handle it a different
way you know because if he's if the
player himself is on the other side of
the table you don't want to you want to
be cognizant of the relationship without
the buffer there of an agent to take
care of it so
um it does seem like you know and
listening to eric decosta talk the
general manager there it does sound like
they're very cognizant of of of of what
lamar wants and they're cognizant of
what his timeline is to get paid
um it does feel like the relationship
there is in a really good place and that
is so key specifically in this situation
because lamar is representing himself um
and so i would expect that something
will get done before the season but but
but you know like until it's done it's
it's it's not done you know so right
we'll see where it goes and and usually
those negotiations there are bumps along
the way and you know it'll be
interesting to see you know how that
goes with the star quarterback when he
doesn't have an agent sort of providing
that buffer for him yeah i mean decosta
was talking just a few weeks ago albert
and i played that sound bite on the show
too that you know
it sounded like him saying like whenever
he's ready we're here like we're ready
to talk like you know but um we're going
on his timetable you know like that's
what it sounded like to me and normally
so you got one guy in murray
who's like
time's ticking folks year three's over
and despite the way that things have
finished out all three years i'm clearly
generationally talented where's my money
it sounds like the other guy's like yeah
we'll get to it you know i mean am i
wrong or is that is that no you aren't
and that's
i mean that's
it it's sort of interesting because if
you if you've been around lamar yeah
it's it's not surprising that he'd be
the guy to do that right like he's just
he's just got a different way about him
and you know i'm sure he wants to get
paid like everybody wants to get paid
but
i don't know that it's like as front of
mind a thing
for for him as it is for some other
people you know and so
yeah you know i i think that it's just
i think for for
for somebody like lamar that's like
again like the relationship with the
team is so important and the fact that
he's got this approach where i mean he
really like
i mean like it's almost like a school
pride thing with him like the ravens
program has become his program you know
and i think the
the the
you know eric decosta john harbaugh
they're all cognizant of what he's meant
to them and and how like just linked
they've become to him because the way
that they sort of turned upside down
what they do offensively and made it
work for him and they've developed him
and all that different stuff and so
um i think the relationship carries them
through
but yeah i mean it's definitely a
different approach and like how
just cool and calm and disgusting he
seems the whole situation like you said
like it's almost like the opposite of
the way kyle is approaching it really is
amazing to contrast albert i'll i'll see
you out there in indy heading there
tonight absolutely we'll see you soon
trip out here thanks brother you too
i'll see you soon albert breer uh
everybody follow him i must follow
always love my chats with him man hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here